gas prices continue to spike hitting
levels uh high levels for both consumers
and businesses but could the volatility
of gas prices push consumers to invest
in greener alternatives such as
renewable energy in the home emily do
you think this gas price rise obviously
it's bad news for consumers and
businesses but is there a possibility
that it'll prompt a change in behavior
from individuals will people think right
i'm going to put solar panels on now you
know do you think it could
push some kind of change
well i'm thinking you know basically
everyone would like to have clean
affordable energy without the sort of
price bikes that we've suddenly found
that we're all having to respond to um
as a result of having that big reliance
as we still currently do um in terms of
oil and gas for you know heating our
homes and powering our powering our
transport and renewable technologies you
know do offer an alternative but in
themselves they're they're not
sufficient because you might say well
what's going to happen if the wind
doesn't blow or the sun doesn't shine
aren't we similarly going to get those
price spikes so it absolutely needs to
be combined with investment in things
like smart grids to balance supply and
demand better but also in terms of
energy storage grid scale energy storage
so that we can store up um the energy
when the wind is blowing and then use it
when the wind is blowing less
you're nodding there dan
yeah it's really interesting i
completely agree what emily says i mean
my interest really is in the home
and buildings i think and from my
perspective there are some more
expensive technologies and i think that
can
run the risk of actually making people
not want to participate but there are
cheaper things that can be done i think
from a consumer's perspective there are
some cheaper options and some more
expensive ones too well yeah and on that
i'm just gonna take a look at a
statistic i found really interesting the
average cost of a solar panel system is
almost six thousand pound that's fifty
percent cheaper than 10 years ago so
it's really interesting how prices are
coming down but it's still a big outlay
for an individual isn't it
in the first instance we would actually
push people towards things that are easy
to do like insulation for example energy
efficiency measures maybe get a smart
thermostat uh look at which rooms you
need energy in and which ones that you
you don't aerated shower heads there are
some actual cheaper options and also
shopping around to buy
renewable
electricity from a supplier and then
there are some more expensive options as
well and i think things like heat pumps
and zero emission boilers are going to
play a huge uh role in this transition
over the next decade too we've we've got
about 10 seconds emily have you got one
little tip for consumers here
um
i
i'm going to let you off the hook next
time you come on i might revisit that
and give you a bit of a chance to think
we're out of time though emily and dan
really good to see you thanks very much
indeed